ouais ouais ça pourrait être vrai ça
ressemble vraiment à
[Musique]
euh
c'est tout
[Musique]
étrangère
comme dans notre bureau et je ne savais pas ce qui
allait se passer, la police aimerait-elle
tout à coup fait irruption dans notre bureau et
nous emmène donc cette incertitude est la peur aussi
la société en Russie était très
difficile en fait, après la guerre,
beaucoup de gens ont juste perdu la tête
en Russie, qu'est-ce qu'ils prendraient
comme cette haine envers l'Ukraine haine
envers  nous la colline que nous sommes des traîtres
nous sommes comme des gens de propagande occidentale
comme s'il était difficile de vivre dans une société
qui méprise absolument tout ce qui
vous concerne
étranger
[Musique]
nous avons ouvert les portes à quelques-uns d'entre eux et leur avons
dit d'écrire en russe pour
un  Public russe à propos de la guerre et
bienvenue dans une salle de rédaction qui a en fait utilisé
le mot Guerre
[Musique]
régime étranger [Musique] le régime terroriste actuel si c'est
demain, très probablement, pas l'année prochaine,
improbable, mais un jour peut-être dans une génération,
cela viendra et  que la nouvelle
Russie devra être construite sur la primauté
du droit et sur la liberté des médias et la liberté du
journalisme est un élément très important de
la construction d'une Russie démocratique.
[Musique]